and toward the end is where most people
call it quits yeah you know when i work
with student and i love beginners i work
with beginners more than anybody else
and beginners are always saying to me
when can i sell this am i going to be
able to sell this next week
am i able to sell this the week after
this when is this done peter that's what
they want to know when am i through
and i say to them you're the only one
that can answer that question
because it's up to you how hard do you
want to work how hard you want to work
how how much time do you want to put
into it to sell it
and um this is a field where
um the success rate
uh is is is is is low in the sense that
i think last year 160 spec scripts sold
in hollywood
they're probably 20 000 submitted so
think about that that's not to say you
shouldn't do it because if you have a
dream and passion you can get it done
i've seen it done i just had a student
sell
two scripts to a major studio um now
he's very talented
vladimir is very talented but he's also
been working for
at it for four years so um you
so many people who market script writing
classes um and this is just a marketing
thing and i
i totally get it i'll probably do it too
coming out which is hey you know come
with me you know
five minutes to a fabulous story right
and that's true in the sense that oh i
sketched it out god thank you peter
but it's not gonna be a sold script for
a while
generally it just takes a lot of work so
that those last few dra
the last few polishes of your first
draft um
you need help you need inspiration
that's where i come in with my
spiritual cocaine and i give you notes
that can help you
sort of get reinvigorated about the
story why'd you want to do it in the
first place
you gotta it's a marathon it's not a
sprint so you need inspiration along the
way
uh i i like to give that too um
but yes it's that's the truth of it
that's how it really works